[Music]
yeah momentum is definitely a factor for
for all players even the strongest
players in the world well I think that's
nonsense I think frankly everyone's
different I think for certain people
maybe it plays a role psychologically
perhaps there's more confidence if you
start off well but I don't feel that at
least for me it makes that big of a
difference
I think momentum is really important
because it's a confidence builder that's
really the main things that when you win
you feel that you're playing well and
that helps you have confidence to keep
on playing well when you're playing
against all elite players I think
certainly that I can play a role getting
off to a very good start I think in a
mixed field it's it's not as big of a
deal perhaps if it's say someone like
Sam for example or Alex and they get off
to a really hot store even bar for that
matter maybe you could play a role but I
think if you look at at the top three I
don't think it really should make that
big of a difference it's all
psychological
and ideally you shouldn't be
psychologically affected from your
losses but it's very hard not to be even
the greatest chess players even Magnus
does feel the pain of the loss and and
starts to lose some confidence lose some
of his momentum for players like Magnus
Carlsen for human no it's good to hold
on because he's like angry and he's
playing better but it's different like
every chess player is unique when you
sort of poorly of course you can recover
and we see examples of players starting
off poorly and recovering all the time
the most important thing probably is to
have enough willpower because the
tournament is really long and everything
is being decided in the last round I
played in 2009 and I was with like
wouldn't ever a game it's like I played
better with every round so for me it was
very like helpful to win up a round
after round I've been in the situations
when you have the momentum and then then
it was one and there is no momentum and
in fact it's getting worse and worse
sometimes there is no recipe you can get
six White's on five legs and you can get
this the best parents ever
have the worst tournament
[Music]